and I also like don't love water a whole
lot I'm scared of it it was one thing
that attracted me to the movie how long
can you hold your breath underwater and
can you guess which Avatar the way of
water actress holds the Hollywood record
for longest time spent holding her
breath these numbers are definitely
going to shock you so make sure you grab
yourself a snack and let's get into it
number one if you guessed Kate Winslet
to be the record holder you'd be right
for her role in avatar The Way of water
Kate held her breath for an astounding 7
minutes and 14 seconds how did she do it
training it's not something I could just
jump in the bath and do right now Kate
trained with a free diving instructor
for about a year while she was working
on the movie and director James Cameron
described her as being a natural in the
water number 2. Mabel Karena almost beat
Kate Winslet's record for her role in
Black Panther wakanda forever Mabel
trained underwater for a year doing
dolphin kicks free Dives and maximizing
her breath holds her record was nearly
seven minutes under water
either way co-star Alex Livin alley
revealed that it was better than anyone
else on the cast could do like no one
even close to her Karena admitted that
it was hard work but said it was worth
it to see it all pay off in the movie
number three can you swim that was one
of the first questions director Ryan
coogler had for tanoch Huerta upon
offering him the role of nemour in Black
Panther wakanda forever his answer I
never drowned before this this response
may have got him through casting but the
truth was tenoch couldn't swim no I
don't know how to swim come on man you
should say that you know because it's
danger he had to undergo the same
difficult training as Mabel Karena but
in his case he started on the basics
eventually tenoch got to the point where
he could hold his breath underwater for
six minutes number four add another
thing to the list of reasons why
Sigourney Weaver is awesome she held her
breath for six minutes on the set of
Avatar the way of water partly by
remaining completely still her freelance
diving instructor also taught her to
think of the urge to breathe as the
dirty villains and you ignore the dirty
villain you go huh you go away she would
then do anything she could to keep her
mind busy number five Isla Fisher
thought it would be the end of her
filming now you see me when her
character climbs into a water tank the
handcuffs she was wearing were magnetic
but the chain wrapping around her wrists
and ankles were secure so when the chain
wound beneath his slat she was trapped I
was banging and saying you know Set Me
Free but everyone just thought I was
doing fabulous acting apparently no one
had prepared a safety signal that would
alert anyone on set to any trouble we're
just glad she made it out alive number
six Daniel Radcliffe wasn't too excited
to have to swim as Harry Potter swimming
is my most hated of all things for the
second challenge of the Triwizard
Tournament in the Goblet of Fire Daniel
had to train in an onset water tank for
six months something that left him with
not one but two ear infections as much
as he hated having to do it at the time
however he looks back on it a bit more
fondly now having apparently come to
realize I will never do that again
number 7. Kristen Stewart is terrified
of swimming you're so subject to your
environment that you're like kind of
utterly helpless when she signed up for
her role in underwater Kristen hadn't
realized that she would be spending the
majority of her time completely
submerged in claustrophobic environments
and wearing 100 pound scuba suit this
was absolutely horrible like the worst
experience I've ever had on a movie
Kristen decided to skip scuba diving
lessons all together apparently telling
director William Eubank just put me in
the suit on the day I don't care it's
going to be so awful number eight Sam
Worthington was given a warning he
admitted that he had a feeling free
diving was going to feature in avatar
The Way of water after James Cameron
told him that was his hobby Sam has said
that the underwater scenes were the
hardest thing he's done in his career
especially considering how emotional
they were you're doing scenes on the day
that I had enough to do on dry land if
you're wondering how he fared against
his co-stars Sam says that his record
for holding his breath is easily 15
seconds number nine you never know how
someone's going to take to the water
Emily Blunt had never had to perform
underwater before the jungle cruise
where she learned how to hold her breath
for up to 30 seconds the underwater
cinematographer would say that working
with blunt was the highlight of the film
for him telling Insider I really admire
Emily's work in this I had no idea what
her Comfort level was in the water she
was Stone Cold with her calmness number
10. Dwayne Johnson is no stranger to
underwater stunts for San Andreas he had
to spend plenty of time performing on a
set flooded with water when it came time
for him to train for his underwater
scenes in Jungle Cruise underwater
cinematographer Ian Seabrook was
surprised by how naturally swimming came
to him saying when Dwayne took his first
breaststroke the first take he did ended
up right on top of me from that point
forward Seabrook had to work extra hard
just to keep up number 11 some find
peace in the water take Daniel Craig for
instance who on the set of Skyfall would
sneak away between takes to nap at the
bottom of the onset water tank Daniel
described it as wonderful being in the
water and admitted that he'd hide down
there for so long that he'd hear other
members of the crew asking where's
Daniel his scuba diving experience
definitely came in handy here as well as
the microphones the tank comes equipped
with to better get the attention of
underwater actors number 12 do your
nightmares include drowning yeah I'm
sure it's going to be quite scary Eva
Green said that her underwater scene for
Casino Royale felt exactly like a
nightmare even though she spent plenty
of time in rehearsals with a mouthpiece
she still wound up swallowing a lot of
water it was quite scary at the
beginning to make matters worse although
she had rehearsed the scene in
Clearwater on the actual day of filming
she discovered that the water was going
to be murky which only made it that much
harder to see number 13 is there a stunt
Tom Cruise won't try the underwater
scene in Mission Impossible Rogue nation
was filmed in one continuous shot
meaning that Tom Cruise needed to hold
his breath on set for six minutes
it's not pleasant he said his naturally
low heart rate helped him but he also
trained with free divers on ways to slow
his heart rate even more apparently Tom
got so good at it that even in his
day-to-day life he'd suddenly realize
he'd stop breathing and I had to turn my
autonomic system back on to breathing it
number 14 it isn't all fun and games
being
here in Edgerton trained to hold breath
for up to minute and 20 seconds it's
quite uh it's quite scary mentally quite
and that isn't even the scariest part on
the first day of filming for the
underwater scene a computer malfunction
caused the entire cast and crew to be
dropped unexpectedly into around 20 feet
of water director Matthew Vaughn would
later describe the incident saying those
actors weren't acting they were
absolutely terrified number 15 do you
have a competitive side Margot Robbie
does no one needs to drown over this on
the set for Suicide Squad she's competed
with her stunt double to see who could
hold their breath the longest Margot
tried to end the competition when she
reached five resting minutes underwater
considering she'd already done better
than she thought she could but when her
stunt double came back with five and a
half minutes Margot tried to go again
prompting the studio to shut the
competition down the scene takes one
minute you don't need to do this these
actors had to go to some difficult
extremes to get that perfect shot and we
love them all the more for it which
underwater filming experience do you
shudder the most to think about make
sure to let us know down in the comments